Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux !
J'espère que vous avez passé
un bon réveillon et que vous n'avez
pas trop la gueule de bois.
- Ça fait mal !
- Je vais parler doucement.
Avant toute chose,
je tenais à vous souhaiter une bonne année
à toutes et à tous.
D'autant qu'elle va être longue
cette année.
Vous êtes sûrement déjà au courant,
elle va durer 366 jours et non 365
comme c'est le cas habituellement.
Une année bissextile
comme on dit, alors ce n'est pas
la première fois que ça arrive.
Cet événement
se produit tous les quatre ans.
Alors pourquoi ajouter un jour de plus
au calendrier tous les quatre ans ?
Enfin, presque tous les quatre ans ?
On va éclaircir tout ça.
D'habitude,
le mois de février ne compte que 28 jours,
mais cette année, il en comptera un de plus :
le 29 février.
Pour celles et ceux qui sont nés ce jour là,
c'est un peu pénalisant.
Leur anniversaire n'a lieu
qu'une fois tous les quatre ans.
C'est le cas
par exemple de l'acteur Gérard Darmon.
Il est né le 29 février 1948.
À la date d'aujourd'hui, il a donc 75 ans.
Et pourtant il n'a fêté son anniversaire que 18 fois.
Alors pourquoi ajoute-t-on
un jour supplémentaire au calendrier ?
Eh bien, c'est tout simplement
pour rattraper le temps perdu.
Une année, vous le savez,
correspond au temps que met la Terre
pour faire le tour complet du Soleil
et revenir à sa position initiale.
Plus précisément, le temps que met la Terre
pour revenir à la position
qu'elle occupait au moment de l'équinoxe
du printemps. Dans les régions tempérées,
là où notre calendrier a été mis au point,
il est en effet très important
de déterminer avec précision le début
et la fin des saisons
et de ne pas se décaler.
Ça permet de savoir quand il faut semer,
tailler ou récolter.
C'est sous Jules César que le calendrier de 365 jours
a été instauré avec des mois
comprenant 30 ou 31 jours,
à l'exception du mois de février
qui en compte 28.
Auparavant, l'année faisait 355 jours
et on ajoutait un mois supplémentaire
d'une durée variable
dans la foulée du mois de février.
Et c'est aussi Jules César
qui a instauré les années bissextiles
en 46 avant Jésus-Christ.
Vous le voyez, ça ne date pas d'hier.
Mais pourquoi il a fait ça ?
Parce qu'il s'est aperçu
enfin, lui et ses astronomes,
que pour revenir à sa position initiale,
la Terre, dans sa course autour du Soleil,
ne mettait pas 365 jours,
mais un tout petit peu plus :
365 jours
et un quart de jour supplémentaire.
Et que si on n'en tenait pas compte,
eh bien, on prendrait une journée d'avance
tous les quatre ans.
Ainsi, en 42 avant Jésus-Christ,
on fêterait le Nouvel An
le 30 décembre et non pas le 31,
c'est-à-dire une journée avant que la Terre
ne revienne à la place qu'elle occupait
un an plus tôt.
Pour corriger le tir, on a donc ajouté
une journée supplémentaire au calendrier
tous les quatre ans, le fameux 29 février.
Ces années-là
ont été qualifiées de bissextiles.
Mais pourquoi un 29 février ?
Et pourquoi une année bissextile ?
Il sort d'où, ce mot-là ?
Parce qu'à l'époque
où les années étaient plus courtes,
avant Jules César, quand le calendrier
comptait moins de jours,
on ajoutait une période
dans la foulée du mois de février.
Par conséquent, quand il s'est agi
d'ajouter un jour supplémentaire,
c'est tout naturellement vers le mois
de février que les maîtres du temps romains
se sont tournés.
Quant au mot bissextile,
il signifie deux fois sixième.
Le jour intercalaire à l'origine,
était placé après le 24 février,
c'est-à-dire le sixième jour
avant les calendes de mars.
Il doublait ce jour,
d'où "bissextile".
Maintenant,
comment savoir si une année est bissextile
justement ?
C'est simple, elle doit être divisible par
4 et le résultat doit être entier.
Autrement dit, fournir un nombre rond,
comme on dit.
Sans virgule, si vous préférez.
2024, par exemple, divisé par 4 = 506
Nombre entier, c'est une année bissextile.
divisé par 4 = 475, chiffre rond.
- 1900 oui !
- Eh bien non.
Comment ça, non ?
Les années séculaires, c'est-à-dire
les années qui finissent par deux zéro
comme 1800,1900 ou 2000,
doivent être divisibles par 4
et par 400 et fournir un résultat rond.
Or, 1900 divisé par 400 = 4,75.
Ce n'est donc pas une année bissextile.
Et 2100 ne le sera pas non plus.
Je ne comprends pas,
on dit tous les quatre ans.
Pourquoi supprimer des années
bissextiles ?
L'histoire ne s'arrête pas là.
C'est plus subtil.
Sinon, je n'aurais pas fait une vidéo
sur le sujet.
Je reprends : Jules César
et ses astronomes avaient fixé
la durée de l'année à 365,25 jours.
En réalité,
la Terre met un peu moins de temps
pour revenir à sa position initiale.
365,2422.
Oh, tu chipotes, ça fait onze minutes !
Onze minutes
et quatorze secondes précisément.
D'une année sur l'autre, c'est peu,
mais à la longue, ça fait beaucoup.
Ça représente une journée
tous les 128 ans.
Ce qui a fini par poser un problème
avec le calendrier religieux,
certaines fêtes ayant lieu à date fixe,
comme Noël le 25 décembre,
mais d'autres étant fluctuantes car fixées
par rapport au calendrier lunaire.
Pâques par exemple.
À ce rythme, on fêterait donc les
cloches avant Noël.
Impensable, vous imaginez bien !
C'est pour cette raison
qu'en 1582, le pape Grégoire XIII
a décidé
de retirer certaines années bissextiles.
On l'a vu, dans la mesure où l'écart
s'élève à un jour d'avance
tous les 128 ans,
cela fait deux jours tous les 256 ans
et trois jours tous les 384 ans.
Il a donc été décidé
de supprimer trois jours tous les 400 ans.
Pas d'un seul coup, évidemment.
En fait,
il a été décidé que 1700, 1800,1900,
qui comptaient
366 jours dans le calendrier julien,
le calendrier de Jules César,
ne seraient plus bissextiles.
2000, en revanche, le resterait.
Bref, à partir de 1582,
ne sont bissextiles
que les années divisibles par 4
et les années centenaires
divisibles par 4 et 400,
avec un résultat entier.
Drôle d'année, 1582.
Pour remettre les pendules à l'heure,
enfin, faire coïncider le calendrier
civil, ou plutôt
religieux à l'époque,
avec le calendrier solaire,
on a retiré certaines années bissextiles.
Mais ce n'est pas la seule transformation
qu'on a fait subir au calendrier
cette année-là.
T'as raison ! En 1582,
on est passé directement
du 4 au 15 octobre.
C'est dingue, ça !
Vous lirez aussi parfois que
cette anomalie s'est produite en décembre.
Tout simplement
parce que cette correction ne s'est pas
faite partout au même moment.
En fait, cette année-là, le pape Grégoire
XIII et ses équipes ont fait les comptes.
Ils se sont aperçus
que depuis la décision de Jules César
d'instaurer une année bissextile
systématiquement tous les quatre ans,
autrement dit, depuis que la durée
de l'année était estimée à 365,25 jours
et non 365,2422,
que depuis tout ce temps,
on avait accumulé un retard de dix jours.
Pour remettre les pendules à l'heure,
il fut tout simplement décidé de supprimer
dix jours au calendrier. En 1582,
on est passé directement
du 4 au 15 octobre.
Selon l'INSEE,
un peu plus de 2000 bébés voient le jour
chaque 29 février en France.
Ni plus ni moins que les autres jours.
Ce qui est beaucoup plus rare,
c'est qu'une femme donne naissance
à plusieurs enfants un 29 février.
Je ne parle pas de jumeaux.
Non, des enfants qui naissent deux
29 février consécutifs.
Cela s'est produit à Nantes
il y a quelques années.
Une maman a accouché d'un petit garçon
le 29 février 2012 et quatre ans
plus tard, le 29 février 2016,
elle a donné naissance à une petite fille.
Dans l'Utah, aux États-Unis, une femme
a accouché de trois enfants un 29 février,
en 2004, 2008 et 2012.
La plupart des personnes nées ce jour-là,
c'est le cas de Gérard Darmon,
on en a parlé un peu plus haut,
choisissent en général
de fêter leur anniversaire
la veille, le 28 février.
Pour leur éviter ce désagrément,
l'île de Taïwan a carrément décidé
de supprimer le 29 février
comme date de naissance.
Les bébés qui viennent au monde
ce jour-là sont enregistrés au 28.
Voilà, c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui.
Bon, je sais, commencer l'année
avec des chiffres, c'est un peu compliqué.
Mais comme on dit,
les bons comptes font les bons amis et ça,
c'est une belle promesse pour 2024.
Encore une fois, très bonne année
et à très bientôt
chers Épicurieuses et Épicurieux !